young s'est squeeze écouter aujourd'hui
j'ai pas trop la forme j'ai besoin de
vous me réconforter un peu que vous me
dites vous pensez mais vidéo et de moi
et de choses comme ça donc je pense que
je vais lire vos commentaires négatifs
on a déjà fait une vidéo où on lisait
les commentaires qu'ils avaient sur
youtube les commentaires rigolo et
aujourd'hui on va lire les commentaires
méchants vilains d'arc personnage
comment voit-on com ou poster truc comme
ça vous allez vivre avec son
extraordinaire c'est parti [ __ ] je
retourne sur la chaîne de squeeze je
loue clés comme et là je me rends compte
qu'en fait 90 % des abonnés de squeeze
10 de la merde
trois petits points meilleure le trader
c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant que ces 90 % d'abonnés ce
que tu viens poster en commentaire
vraiment merci 3400 fdp abonnés à cette
chaîne
waouh aucun autre endroit sur terre ne
regroupe autant de fdp au mètre carré
c'est beaucoup de prostituées ou 73
millions 4,5 là rien que là vous
imaginez le nombre de prostituées agnès
latapie paix la borne ont beaucoup trop
long déjà nous dit arrête de sortir des
vidéos tu gagnes certes plein d'argent
mais franchement c'est tout le temps la
même chose
essaye de trouver des choses plus
travailler c'est vrai que ça se
ressemble mais tu peux pas sortir des
vidéos complètement différente quand on
fait autant par semaine ma petite agnès
déjà je suis étonné que à 40 ans tu
suives mes vidéos ça me fait plaisir
et puis là je lis commentaires et d'un
coup le le plaisir est parti il n'est
plus la deuxième chose à dire ce qu'est
ce que t'en à [ __ ] que je gagne blain
ou pas d'argent on se rencontre on bat
les couilles c'est pas ça le problème
apparemment
bref c'est que c'est tout le temps la
même chose et le problème encore plus
grosse et que tu sais pas écrire certes
[ __ ] alors t'as 40 en recul - agnès
paul je me suis emporté l'impression
d'être le même coup que les gens qui
rient ce genre de commentaires
actuellement c'est horrible ah la la
j'adore vraiment ce quiz et comme
youtube heures il est génial mais je
voudrais parler d'une chose qui on n'a
rien à voir je m'appelle égouts et je
vais écouter sur youtube en quelques
vidéos je suis déjà juste à bout des
machines est super bien vous avez vous
abonner au 95e pour ce commentaire
vraiment bien bon il est pas méchant
mais c'est rigolo peut dire du staff des
mois dan huss nous dit alors j'ai perdu
ce qui vous dit vous quel mois nous ont
soudés jamais vous arrête de faire des
vidéos squeeze c'est de la merde
waouh merci dé mon anus c'est très
constructif abonne toi ma chaîne alors
maximimum été le plus gros l'âge qu'on
ait fait un max kelly lieu c'est pas
possible
cet homme pourrait dire qu'il faudrait
qu'on crève tous dans notre souffrance
que tu dirais à bothoa machine alors tu
verras c'est mieux ça vaut mieux que ces
scandales après ça me fait de la peine
quand je vois ce que tu fais tu peux
prendre en minuscule je te promets c'est
le même effet sociaux en gueule at
m'engueule la passion n'est clairement
plus la tétée mieux à l'époque de call
of duty
remettons en question sinon dans deux
ans c'est fini un petit peu peu près
calme toi une feuille mais dd sens ça va
aller je m'en suis quand la passion
n'est plus là tu tiens pas deux
embuscades plus de passion donc
finalement au bout de deux mois tu étais
un peu plus donc tu fais n'importe quoi
les gens le remarquent et voilà tout
s'écroule
et ensuite ce petit morceau de phrase tu
étais mieux à l'époque de call of duty
pourquoi on bouge pas l'esprit pourquoi
j'étais mieux éviter combat coupe de la
commission n'était pas mieux elle était
pire encore assez la barbe d'adolescents
foire ou de poils de fès qui est apparu
c'est ça qui déplaît c'est marrant comme
une fille dans une mauvaise période là
où tu viens pas beaucoup d'argent
squeeze sur pas beaucoup de vidéos par
rapport à toi hier bourdonnement je dis
ça je dis rien à progresser tu que je
sors le même nom de vidéos tous les mois
sauf en octobre dernier où il y avait
les pédales et une isolation et du coup
je n'ai sorti beaucoup plus mais mois
d'octobre n'est pas le mois le mieux
rémunéré de là mais [ __ ] apprendre la
vie celui-là je vais ptet pas j'adore
alors pourquoi tu viens tu m'emmerdes
des accrocs ghost bon quoi encore une
copie de +10 paille mais en beaucoup
moins drôle je ne m'aime pas lâcher un
sourire
moi j'ai lâché un sourire on va là ta
photo mr et oh ouais ce que je veux dire
j'en peux plus de voir tes vidéos de
merde et ta gueule de condom actualité
youtube
tu en as marre tu en as marre temps à la
barre de moi en tout cas voilà ma du
lourd on à ludovic ludo qui nous dit
squeeze t1 fils deux tuniques tu as la
douceur tous les soirs tu en as ton père
va t'es un mec du mieux à ce moment là
ma frange du plus aucun mot quoi tout
chaque mois c'est une insulte à une deux
têtes de cons sa lotus obèses tu obèses
ta mère tu aube est amer gros l'asb est
dangereuse menace ça le petit adrien
problème déjà pourquoi tu sens sur cette
dernière insulte alors que les 124
hôtels sont passés nickel dans ta phrase
tu rends chez doigt d'honneur ludovic
ludo je vous passe avec moi tu plagie
surplus dit pareil tu recopies les jeux
du le blédard tu plagie moins qu il
je suis désolé mais plagiat s'érode sous
la chaleur et l'eau chaude l'eau frette
et au crayon ou plus d'achats du mec
danser après la guerre ce quiz des
abattoirs ma chaîne turque j'en ai
besoin
phoenix musculation tu insinue que ça
c'est trop petit tu peux la raison
phoenix musculation de la merde pour
gamin est petite chienne comme
d'habitude avec d'avoir une écoutable de
puceau et les zooms raté à la più di pa
y recycle le toit au nom a besoin encore
d'argent c'est vrai mais qu'est ce qui
se passe les clubs pourquoi tout est
toujours reliée à l'argent mais c'est ma
pause les recéder petite chienne regarde
mes vidéos des chaînes j'entends par là
l'animal
je suis intéressé voilà contacter jumbo
c'est mon manager bizarrement il va tout
vous refusez sais pas pourquoi il était
papa possessive jobourg la chaîne comme
nous du sahel clos je déteste ces
youtuber qui gagnent de l'argent en
faisant de la merde je comprends pas
tout le monde pourrait faire la même
chose que lui c'est juste un gars qui
veut gagner de l'argent quel con ça
m'énerve
la carte se casser du tube bien que tout
ce que j'ai dis où tu es faut que
j'adore youtuber continue comme ça péter
still there they put red steel 2
problème comment
tu es nul tu sais pas jouer tu fais
pitié tu sais pas dessiner t'es moche tu
choisis des cheveux bourita rien pour
toi si tu aurais tu fais un truc marotte
elle s'appelle the bay sera jeu bon bah
tout et justifie alors je te pardonne
tes une rolex salle riche bientôt ras
des dents en or mais une chose à dire vu
les dents jaunes que j'ai fab son jardin
au moulias retard culturel qu'est ce qui
se passe en mon dieu c'est le retour de
ludovic lutte deux hommes très célèbre
sale [ __ ] de squeeze way tgt gtoi me
parle pas connard mais il n'avait pas
parlé ludovic ludo il m'avait parlé à
moi donc ne vit plus doute une insulte
pas le dôme xv audois s'il te plaît
[ __ ] c'est quoi ce bordel 27 vie des
russes j'espère que ça vous a plu
j'avais envie de faire ça parce que je
trouvais qu'il ya des commentaires qui
sont tellement débile que c'est hilarant
vraiment bon j'espère vous avez au moins
et si c'est un petit sourire tout ça
pour dire que dans les côtés on retrouve
de tout et de rien en soi il ya une mode
c'est de mettre un commentaire une
blague et d'avoir le plus de pouce vert
et c'est un peu con que je trouve que
l'espace commentaires ci fait pour
parler de la vidéo après c'est vrai que
l inverse des commentaires combien de
fois il ya des commentaires vraiment
adorable de personnes qui juste avant
leur soutien qui ou même des fois ils
font des critiques constructives ou quoi
et ça fait super plaisir
c'est un bien plus [ __ ] de vic le dos
et a plus de vie clos avec ton evil
within et on nous a donné un cachet
aujourd'hui servi dans une nouvelle
vidéo merci à vous regarder le tour des
sites et moi j'espère rendre ça plus
c'est bon
[Musique]